now before we get into the one issue
with his world tour and the reason that
some people are outraged there's one
more key factor in Matt rife's wild
Journey to the top and that is the
beautiful art of crowd work
he didn't do anything he didn't do
anything wrong
in life
did you not have a job the entire time
together
he did
he works like er also you work about a
hero
or a million followers on Instagram is
insane just to put that into context
with some other big name comedians Matt
Rife has more followers than Bill Burr
John Mulaney Theo Von Tom segora Andrew
Schultz and eight times as many
followers as Shane Gillis in fact the
only comedian that I could find with
more followers than Matt Rife is none
other than Joe Rogan